there are writer directors like Oh Billy
Wilder or Onley who aren't born here but
who finds some part of Americana to show
us that we don't know ourselves how did
you find this part of the American story
and how did you find Brady I grew up in
Beijing and I always look at in there
Mongolia the plains somewhere that that
means something very different than the
life I know and I think being in New
York for a long time and wanting to to
go west you need to find a different way
of life to get to know myself better and
ended up on the Pine Ridge Reservation
in South Dakota and I made a movie there
after the first film is finished I went
out to visit and I met Brady on a cattle
ranch on Pine Ridge that's how I started
and so did the story start with Brady
because this was before his accident
it started with I saw him training
horses in the corral I've just never
seen anything like that you know he he
was playing different roles to this wild
young horse he was the father the mother
the friend the dance partner to this
horse and he gets this young horse to
trust him and to communicate with him I
thought that kind of presence that he
has that he might be better boy I only
found our camera so Brady how did Chloe
sell you on the idea of being in a movie
we talked about it several different
times she told me she was a director and
she talked about possibly casting me and
I kind of chuckled about it at first
because I never had an experience doing
anything like this so she came back a
few times that summer and she actually
learned how to ride horses and move cows
and everything and I figured if she's
not scared to get on a twelve hundred
pound horse then why should I be scared
of a camera the crew was small what was
you got a six-person crew right putting
me including you okay so how do you not
be intrusive on a story that's really so
intimate that's for all the vastness of
the plains which you brought out it's
also a very intimate story
yeah I think some of that came out the
fact that me and Brady and you know
Chloe I shot Chloe's first films times
my brothers taught me so by the time it
came to the ride I felt we were just
making a film with our friends really
so I already felt like I had your trust
Brady but I mean also the the intimacy
between the camera and the horses was
achieved through Brady you know the
camera would come into the corral that
smelled the camera would get them used
to me
the boompole and so we're right up
inside it and and so for you to decide
how to structure this was this almost
because it is kind of documentary it is
Brady's story
did you script it very tightly or given
that this is his family this is a place
he knows was there a sense of you
trusted an improv sense in what he was
going to bring out and what his family
would do the script is 65 pages long and
there are part of the scripture says
Brady train horses you know seven
minutes in on screen more Brady and Lily
moments like that but the scripted part
where there's dialogue just like any
other script is heavily inspired by
Brady's real life and all the little
things that Brady said to me in the year
and haven't known him since we shot the
film and to decide to cast the whole
family for this was that from the
beginning or did you think about having
other actors other people do this but
then realized the best story is his
story with his before he got injured we
tried different things I was going to
maybe bring someone from my first film I
wasn't sure but when after he was
injured is very natural to see that the
people's life were mostly impacted by
injury are those who are closest to him
Brady when your family was approached
with the idea of being in the film with
you what did they say
my dad chuckled about it kind of like I
did you know it would take about ten or
twelve cakes boo he always nailed it at
the end
Lily she she'd videotaped everything and
played it back memorized lines and
corded audio you know she loves cameras
so she was always on board with it too
because it seems so spontaneous with
Lily
yeah and Layne Scott he was actually the
year after he was injured he was
actually gonna be on a bull riding
reality show so came natural to him as
well so he was all ready for that so you
guys were pros before anybody had even
approached you about this so and now
that they've seen it what do they think
your dad and Lily in Lane everybody's
pretty impressed with how it came
together none of us had ever acted
before so we didn't really know how the
whole editing process and everything
works so that we were pretty impressed
did things take unexpected turns for you
that the movie that you envisioned is
not what we saw on the screen and how
different is it it's pretty close to the
script and that you know to me I learned
from my first movie which I shot with
the treatment especially with all these
exciting things that's happening around
you is really difficult not to get
sidetracked so have a script that makes
sense
it's really important the more you work
in this ecosystem that you allow things
happen the more you need a script to go
back really yeah I think so you have to
know the rules to break the rules kind
of thing right so what were the
challenges for you were there physical
challenges or was it about catching the
light as you say as you had foreseen a
moment and it eluded you perhaps yeah I
think I challenge it I mean there's
certainly physical challenges with the
five-person crew and you know we close
very smart about almost casting the crew
you know it's five people but that's the
right five people huh you know and
they're not going to be there it's not
your normal film set these that they're
there for a human experience so if you
need to carry a lens cases and you're
the you know producer or the grip carry
the lens case because we're all doing
this together so there are limitations
to that to answer your question but I
feel close so smart in scheduling this
film that we never really felt rushed or
we never really felt overly worked it
was
a lot of sitting around waiting for the
light to be just right well thank you
for a wonderful film and I think the
audience would like to say thank you
[Applause]